hey guys you're about to watch a clip
that I did in 2013 where I kind of
started telling the world of my intent
or belief in a snapchat you know I also
wrote this article back in 14 about you
know you disrespecting the ghost when I
think it's got huge upside I think
2016-2017 are gonna be the years were in
the marketing world and the business
world really recognized what's actually
happening in snapchat which is snapchat
right this minute is the closest thing
to Facebook two thousand seven and eight
that I've seen since then and and I just
you know this is almost like a last
ditch effort video to try to get you
into a place of like this is gonna
happen you need to figure it out there's
a lot of nuances within snapchat you
need to get in there become native
because it's going to be a massively
important massively important platform
I think snapchats gonna open up their
platform and will be one to one and I
think brands and businesses can send the
snap to 10,000 people that are following
them and that when they open it for
those 10 seconds they're actually paying
attention yeah and so what if the snap
said take a picture the screenshot of
this and scan at the register for 10%
off I think people will do things like
that or take a snapshot of this and
tweet it at me and I'll give you my
ebook for free now you've got people
putting out tweets to their community
with you on it
yeah got it so I think there's a lot of
gamification that can happen snapchat
you know why the snapchat forces you to
pay attention email Facebook Twitter we
think we can get back to it they'll be
email me I'll see you again in my screen
snapchat you know that once you could
look at it it disappears forever yeah
which requires you to actually pay
attention yes and so what we are all in
the business of attention and everybody
worries about the hot top line how many
visitors do you have email followers
that doesn't matter it matters top-line
matters but conversion is what matters
and snapchat focus on conversion in my
opinion